can you describe what the
uh
new morris pratt algorithm does
and how did you come to develop it one
of the many things that you're known for
and has your name attached to it yeah
all right so
it should be actually morris pratt knuth
but we decided to use alphabetical order
when we published the paper
the problem is
uh something that everybody knows now if
they're
if they're using the search engine uh
uh
you have a
a large collection of text
and you want to know if
if the word
canoeith appears anywhere in the text
they'll say or
or some
some other word that's less interesting
than kind of
that's the most interesting thing
or something mega morris right
so we have we have
a large piece of text and it's all
one long one-dimensional thing you know
it's a first or second letter
et cetera et cetera et cetera
and so uh
the question you would like to be able
to do this quickly
um
and the obvious way is that let's say
we're looking for morris then don't know
that so we would we would go through and
wait till we get to letter m then we'd
look at the next word and sure enough
it's an o and then an r
but then that
too bad
um
the next letter is is e
so we missed we missed out on morris
and so
uh we go back and start looking for
another
okay all over again so that's the
obvious way to do it
all right
um
and and jim morris noticed
there was a more clever way
to do it and
the obvious way would have started
let's say we
you know we found that letter m at
character position 1000.
so it was started next at character
position 1001
[Music]
but
but he but he said no look we we already
read the o and the r
and we know that they aren't m's
so we could we could start
we don't have to read those over again
all right so um and this gets pretty
tricky when
when the word isn't morris but it's more
like
abracadabra where you have patterns that
are occurring uh
like repeating patterns
at the beginning at the middle right
right so so um
he worked it out
and he put it into the system software
at berkeley i think it was where he was
uh he was writing some berkeley eunuchs
i think was some routine that was
supposed to find occurrences of patterns
in texas and and
and uh
we didn't explain it
and and so he found out that several
months later somebody had
had looked at it didn't look right and
so they ripped it out
so he had this this algorithm but it
didn't make it through
you know because he what wasn't
understood
nobody knew about this particularly
von pratt
also had independently
discovered it a year or two later
i forget why
i think
vaughn was studying some
technical problem
about palindromes or something like that
he wasn't really it juan wasn't working
on
on text searching but he was working on
on an abstract problem that
that was related well
at that time steve cook was a professor
at berkeley uh
and uh
uh what it was the
greatest mistake that
berkeley cs department made was not to
give him tenure and so steve went to
went to toronto but um
but i but i knew steve while he was at
berkeley
and he had come up with a
with a very peculiar theorem
uh
about a technical concept called a stack
automaton
and a stack automaton it is a machine
that
that it can't do everything a touring
machine can do but it
it can only look at
something on
at the top of a stack or it can put more
things on the stack or or it can take
things off the stack
like it can't remember a long string of
symbols but but it can remember them in
reverse order so so if you tell a stack
of thomas on abcde
it it can it can tell you afterwards
edcba uh
you know it doesn't have any other
memory except
except this one thing that it can see
and and steve cook proved this amazing
thing that says
if a stack automaton can recognize a
language
where the strings of the language are
length n
in any um
amount of time whatsoever
to the stack automaton you might use a
zillion steps a regular computer can
recognize that same language in time n
log n
so steve had a way of transforming
a a computation that goes on and on and
on
into using different data structures
into something that you can do on a
regular computer uh fast
the stack of timezone goes slow but
but but but somehow the fact that it can
do it at all
means that there has to be a fast way
so i thought this was a pretty
you know cool theorem
and so i tried it out on on a problem
where i knew
a stack automaton could do it
but i couldn't figure out a fast way to
do it on a regular computer i thought i
was a pretty good programmer
but
but by golly
i couldn't think of any way to recognize
this language
efficiently
so i went through steve cook's
construction
i filled my blackboard
with all the
everything that stack thomas undone
did you know i i wrote down and and then
i tried to
see patterns in that
and
and how did he convert that into a
computer program on a regular machine
um and
finally i psyched it out
what was what was the thing i was
missing so that i could
say oh yeah this is what i should do in
my program
uh
and now i have an efficient program
and and so i
uh
i i would never have thought about
like
that if i hadn't had his theorem which
was purely abstract thing
here to try to intuit how to use the
stack automaton for the the string
matching problem yeah so so so the the
problem i
i i had
started with was not the string matching
problem but then i realized that the
string matching problem was another
thing which would also be
could be done by a stack automaton and
and so when when i looked at what that
told me
then i had a nice algorithm for this
string matching problem uh and and it
told me
exactly what i should remember as i'm as
i'm going through the string
and i worked it out and and i wrote this
little paper called
automata theory can be useful
and and the reason was that it was first
i mean i had been reading all kinds of
papers about automated theory
but it never taught me it it never
improved my programming for for everyday
problems uh it was something that you
published in journals and and you know
it was it was interesting stuff but it
but here was a case where i couldn't
figure out how to write the program i
had a theorem from automated theory then
i knew how to write the program so this
was
for me
uh
you know a change in life i started to
say maybe i should
learn more about thomas
and
and and i i showed this note to juan
pratt and he said
that's
similar to something i was working on
um and then uh and and jim morris was at
at berkeley too at the time
anyway he
he he's had an illustrious career but i
haven't kept
track of jim but one is my colleague at
stanford
and my student uh later but but this was
before one
one was still a graduate student and
hadn't come to stanford yet so we found
out that we'd all been working on the
same thing so so it was our algorithm we
each discovered it independently but
each of us had discovered a different
a different part of the elephant
you know a different
aspect of it so we could put our
our
our things together it was my job to
write the paper
how did the elephants bring to life
spring to life was
because i
i had drafted this paper
autonomous theory
oh it can be useful which was seen by
vaughn and then by jim and then then we
combined
because maybe they had also
been thinking of writing something up
about it
you